the lights are off
it is time
to get spooky i am just about to play
the first hour or so if there's like a
chapter break before that that makes
more sense to end i'll do that uh of a
game called madison which i've been
looking forward to for quite some time
made by a relatively small team but i
know that it has photography elements
which made me think of fatal frame which
is my one of my favorite horror games
slash survival horror games ever so i've
been really looking forward to it i'm
expecting
to be pretty spooked
and my plan is to play the first hour
here on youtube as i always do before
moving over to stream it on twitch maybe
over the weekend um
[Music]
let's do it okay i'm just gonna make
myself smaller
and we
i'm gonna jump right in new game
normal
it says visual hints photography zones
normal enemies infinite instant photos
auto save
doesn't seem like a huge difference
other than no visual hints and no
photography zones but i'm gonna go
normal
let's go
the amount of items you can carry is
eight use the safe to store items you
don't need okay it's very resident evil
i gotcha
i don't really know what i'm in for
overall i have intentionally avoided
watching trailers i just kind of heard
about this game knew it was coming out
today and uh
got excited
hard mode was designed for those let's
go if you find yourself in the dark try
to light your way with the camera's
flash
oh that's awful that's just like that um
there's a scene in seoul where a
character does that
that's terrifying also yeah the the game
is italicized not italicized or
capitalized as capital m a d lowercase i
capital s o n
and i don't know why i imagine that
means something that the eye is
lowercase and the rest of the the game
title is
uppercase
i'm curious about it in any case it's
interesting marketing choice they've
made there
and right now you guys can't see it but
the
little loading symbol that's on the
bottom right is
a capital i
like rotating in a polaroid
but otherwise i would say this is a very
long
load
it's like a minute or so maybe which
makes me think game big maybe i guess
we'll see
bloodiest games
oh my god
crying or laughing
can't show me that
just answer me that what was the
question
your whole family
your blood
what the hell are you thinking
what in the hell crossed your mind
he's crying [ __ ] is happening to you
you've ruined our family
what am i going to do now
hush
did you lock me in here no are we
related
oh i didn't realize i was controlling it
yet okay
i'm still there bud
okay
no no
no this this can't be happening
god interesting voice acting that's
somebody's dismemberment
oh oh there's two pictures and that's a
leg
did i do that maybe
um
it is
very dark in here oh
oh this is like a whole house is that
the front door maybe
dad
okay
nice brick you got there
that's oh my god you have to move the
controller so far i don't want to do
that yet let me explore first
a little bit scope some stuff out yeah
that corner so dark
tv was causing the flicker oh okay i
expected this to like have a whole
downstairs or something like the whole
house but
it's actually very small what are you
asking me to rotate
i'm not sure
i have to find it
oh that's safe i think
that's so slow
it's like amnesia
from
your cousin romeo
okay uh
maxwell and family
the nicaragua flag
might be wrong about that
i recognize that flag and i am
embarrassed that i don't know what it is
i am really bad with flags
um okay
i feel like i should have been able to
open this
but i can't see any means to do so
yeah okay
creepy hallway it is
doesn't seem like there's anything here
other than just this
sideboard huh yeah
dad please
please talk to me i don't understand
what's going on
dad stop
you're not making any sense
i don't know dude it seems like you
killed your whole family and your dad's
pretty upset with you
that's just how it seems oh i need to
find something in this room okay
that interacts with the bowl um
tbo
you can okay cool
man it is dark do i maybe need to up the
brightness it maybe shouldn't be this
dark
yeah yeah now i just can't even see
um
let me do it and then potentially turn
it back down
video
options
i can't it has to stay how it is okay
okay i just cannot see a thing
back on so i have a little bit more
light
can you pick up would work or something
like that didn't have anything else in
it right
no justice
i think maybe i have to find the handle
not seeing anything yet
dad
anybody seeing
a handle
oh
oh wow
okay that's what that was for that's
interesting
huh
that's cool that's all like the light
mechanic in this room
i don't know what that noise is that
ticking noise
oh the fan
i have to find the handle
i sure do okay
see if this helps
you find a handle
uh-huh
okay
that's probably what it is
cool
now we have an inventory look at us go
yeah i thought rotate meant like rotate
the camera not rotate the
that
you know a ham is messed up when it for
no reason has bob wire wrapped around it
is that it
okay i think it might have been
all right daddy oh
you want to talk to me and i have a
hammer now
i really could just open that door and
talk to him oh that makes me think that
that was supposed to be a painting there
i can't see a painting i would move
there
interesting
you are not my son
you are not my son you're not
technically wrong sir i don't know you
come on
maybe i can get out through grandpa's
house
i gotta get out of here
okay
that's obviously not gonna work
i wonder where i'm gonna find the camera
and what it's gonna be for you need to
find a way out i know
before dad notices i'm here
i can't use it okay
can't pick up any of these
i wonder if i'm actually on a timer
probably not it's probably it's probably
a scripted event
maxwell
okay
wasn't there a door here
interesting oh
okay
that's strange
maybe i'm nutty oh
that thing moved
right
don't like these noises oh god
i won't be able to go back
i like got like like hot like oh
okay
okay got it noted
spooky clock say hi oh that's changed
yeah no it hasn't okay
this is open now
it's one of these games
where stuff
changes environments change that's so
unsettling
oh hello
all right okay hey
you looking at me oh you're actually
kind of just a cute old man
i apologize for
judging you so harshly
don't worry about it grandpa was just
like
a lot of noises in this room can you not
can you chill out please for just a
second could you chill
everybody [ __ ] chill out
it's gonna be creepy as hell it must be
broken
oh or not okay that's good take that
anything else this is a lot of pictures
of the same woman with white eyes
all righty okay okay cool uh
it's gonna require some kind of
have a combination of any kind this is
chasing me
i think right like if i turn around it
follows me
no i feel like it's shifted but maybe
i'm wrong
all right
like my birthday present oh i'm 16 my
name is luca how did it get here
okay good to know
very cute
that's the camera
stop moving what the [ __ ] is moving
well i guess i want to yeah i want to
take it right yeah
oh god
that's kind of nice just a little tink
do that that's comforting i like that
uh that was over there before right or
there's two of them now
to use camera
oh god
shake
this is gonna be so scary have i only
been playing for 13 minutes
okay
seems fine over there
and then one over here
shake was this no shake was was oh i
forgot what shake is okay hang on
chill out yeah
zoom
i'm not seeing any numbers which is what
i'm expecting to find
can i open these
draw cockroaches gross yeah
draws what's this
okay i'll take that you ain't no ticket
ticket
that's still not working okay
go out and find numbers i guess
cool wait is that new no
the numbers on any of these it could be
308 2
4308
how about you let's just take a picture
of this obviously
it just seems like a thing it would want
me to take a picture of
looks the same
um we could try for 308
i can't imagine that'll actually work
though
uh
scroll
okay
again don't think this is actually gonna
work but we'll try it
eight
huh
nothing
what's this one
same picture
all right
i do have unlimited pictures it did say
that so
nothing there stink
um
head back out what could go wrong i have
a key now
it's locked
oh you told me i didn't find everything
in here that i'm supposed to find
all right what's going on down here
light it up for me
stop with the [ __ ] noises dude
are the pictures the numbers are the
pictures relevant at all maybe
um that's really dark
don't like that didn't like that one bit
[Music]
picture back there
okay oh that seems fine what
could go wrong
just my scary dad out here trying to
kill me
oh [ __ ]
why is there something that's
threatening me
[ __ ] hell this has no right to be
this creepy
all right
try and use the sturdy key no
can't okay
this then
can't see about where have you gone oh
my god oh my god oh my god oh my god i
hate it
i don't care what you have on you
can't use it on this either
[ __ ] dude
[Music]
[ __ ]
[ __ ] this hallway
[ __ ]
maybe i should be looking at all the
pictures
a bit more carefully what's happened
here
that's the same
all right i feel like that look at that
let's just close that
yeah we don't need anything to do with
you okay
this room doesn't appear to have changed
maybe
oh that's a noose now
oh that's fun
um
i can pick these up i think right
i can't pick that up can i pick this one
up
[Music]
nice synth serial killer
i can't really make any of it out i
don't know if that's my eyes i'm not
supposed to shot by police in 1984.
does that say what's it what's a door
was it there
interesting so that's where that door
used to be
[Music]
[Music]
during a witchcraft ceremony as you do
he was then
cool yeah and now for the weather
all right did that change anything
maybe it's added a door out here for me
or changed something out here
no
nothing yet
oh the portrait will go up here
i should find a nail or something to
hang it with you didn't have to say that
so dramatically my dude i should find a
nail or something oh that's gone back
didn't that move
ah
okay
oh that's convenient well thanks really
appreciate that my nice clock friend
really helping out
[Music]
seems fine actually
not a problem
okay
my own hammer scared the [ __ ] out of me
all right cool
did that do anything
no
surely it did something
somewhere somehow
you take a picture of it now
oh god
that's probably what i was supposed to
do yes
oh it's pointing
whoo
behind me
ah
that's cool
not like fatal frame as it turns out
that was cool
okay
this is where the spooky [ __ ] went
madison hale 43 years old serial killer
serial killer madison hale was shot down
to death these really bad journalists
several grammatical errors that's all
right uh who had just testified to have
found her dismembering her victims
inside a well of her property
what the hell has dad been doing here
looking up madison hale apparently
madison agonized a few hours before she
died
witchcraft or mental illness one of
life's greatest mysteries
dad said he was repairing grandpa's
house
but instead he's been investigating this
woman well i think that that is
what's going on is because he thinks
that because you have the camera that
you're doing it
43 year old
43 years old satanist woman killed her
own family during a witchcraft ceremony
believe it or not the 43 years old woman
was found taking pictures of one of her
madison hale dumped her victim's bodies
inside a well in her basement serial
killer was fatally shot in the stomach
dreadful pictures of the victims bodies
were found in hale's basement the woman
took pictures of the dead bodies after
dismembering
officer russells testifies as informed
by the police department the officer
that
ended madison's life testifies that
no one really sounded like it came from
the right
which i don't love because that door was
closed and i don't know what's through
it
the 43 year old woman is suspected to
have taken pictures of her victim
victims once mutilated
after a long history of incidents saint
jupiter's cathedral is all the rage once
again upon confirmation that will hold a
public week in honour of the solar 43
year old serial killer madison hale
who murdered a total of four people last
month the wake will be in public and
free and according to the pre-saving
sayings
they will seek to eliminate madison soul
with divine light allowing her to pee
under the gates of heaven why would
anyone want to redeem her that seems
weird
ah you know he's crazy when he's running
on the walls how else would you know
oh cool
you join that
nothing
bunch of pictures oh this door over here
too
okay
go this way
i am spooked i'll tell you that
i am
spooked
a cassette
all right
okay
now we spin it
take store uh is there anything in it
my notebook store
so dad's the one who took it away from
me
i probably don't need to
store anything really
no i'm all right
uh can i look at your notebook my dude
seven
interrupt
i don't remember drawing any of these
sister's leg am i
going insane
mom's arm dad's head so we have these
two
we don't have dad's head and dad's not
dead yet
i agree with your dad dude i think you
should lock your ass back up
dad was right listen to dad
did that move no that was always there
um
hmm
jesus christ
i'm now wondering if these
are
these are all those pictures i've taken
this is excessive i've taken a lot of
pictures you know what let's just get
rid of most of them
because i don't feel like any of them
have really been useful except for
the pointing one obviously
which is that one
that's useless
that unlocked something so we'll keep
that useless useless
useless useless useless useless
very resident evil
eight biohazard looking kitchen i
haven't been here since he died
this is huge
huge
[ __ ]
this storm must have taken up the power
oh
great what the [ __ ] i think grandpa had
a generator in the basement is that a
body on the floor
i think it is
oh
okay
well this is fun
go find
the basement which is always a great
vibe if you ask me
why can't i take it
well let me take it why
okay
it has no signal well yeah of course
that's
something that prompted me to move
something
what a hand come up
i saw it i did
that seems like i should be able to take
that cassette player
does it not
where's the hand
yeah
oh it's just for the draw okay
which i am not opening well
what do you got for me draw nothing
how about you
also nothing okay i still think you
should let me interact with that but
maybe we just have to wait till that was
on all right
how y'all doing y'all you're pretty cute
grandpa's room
locked
basement
bathroom okay
[Music]
bathroom and basement are two very
different things
uh
is that a dead body over there as well
okay
this seems like
direction
of a basement
if not
basement itself
[Music]
no if i do them all on it goes wrong too
so
up down
up up down
i'm surprised it's not letting me do
that one
down
up up
up down up
up up
up down
oh
okay
i really would have guessed it was a
more dramatic
setup than that um okay let's go back up
and
explore more i guess
or should i go back maybe
i think i might go back to that first
room and
do the clock just like cross things off
the list i'm almost positive there's a
dead body in this [ __ ] kitchen man
just a sheet i
can use this now i think maybe
from the moment of first contact
it is already too late
when a demon attaches itself to a human
demons
it becomes a parasite of sorts
it feeds from the host until
it devours every last part of their soul
okay in most instances the demon's
relentless objective is to get back to
the world of the living of course
if you want to break that link
well
i'm afraid it's no simple matter
i could speak at length about various
rituals and procedures
but by far the best way is to obey
help the demon attain that which it
seeks why would you do that only then
will the demon leave of its own accord
usually they enter
even if you rid yourself of that object
later
the demon has made the contact it needs
and already walks among us okay
so i need to find out what it needs
possession the host human tends to
withdraw from friends and family
becoming
aggressive bad things even violent
this is the result of the spiritual
battle between the host and the entity
both vying for control over the mortal
body
the symptoms that indicate that the
possession is progressing are dizziness
nausea and headaches oh yes a migraine
the latter of which can be so intense
as to render the host that's when
they're implying that i killed my
friends flash family the dark entity
manipulates its host with
visual hallucinations
all right i'm possessed got it okay cool
cool cool cool love that for me the
sanity of the host is for the purpose of
making them
this is how the demon fully exerts its
insidious control
oh and before i forget
several cases of possession
strange behavioral patterns in nearby
insects
cockroaches in particular
my advice
oh really
god okay
oh there's just no way i can't be
possessed todd disagree there must be a
mistake
those pictures that leg that i really
thought that one
dad thinks it was me but i
[Music]
what's happening
is this what that man was talking about
yes you dummy
it can't be happening to me well it
super is okay um
can i
maybe open the notebook
could it be
the basement door
i [ __ ] guess so
so i want to know if i can maybe
like i just need to rotate that but can
i rotate it
in my inventory
it doesn't look like i can right
i mean like if i do that
it's very awkward hang on just a little
bit more
a little bit more like like this like no
like this does it stay that way
no
i guess that's not going to work
maybe it'll work eventually
avoid the cockroaches
avoid the cockroaches
all right
go back
um
but me being possessed actually
huge dub
i'm being honest
not that scary
all right personally
with being possessed i can only carry
eight items right five right now that's
fine okay
yeah i'm uh
i'm down with it
because that means that at least a
demon's not
hurting nobody around me
right
well
rather demons not
i'm
trying to talk to calm myself down and
the words aren't happening and i
apologize i really thought that was dead
body last time it's clearly
not what's this oh you're gonna take
those two
no
okay
[ __ ] hell man
i feel like a dog on 4th of july you
know what i mean
everything's just real [ __ ] jumpy out
here
god this is how you leave your grandad's
house
no respect avoid the cockroaches they
said
but why
i really feel like this wants to be
picked up but i guess not
um
anything to interact with here
no
and avoid the cockroaches i'm gonna just
not go where they are i'm gonna take
that as the game giving me a queue
but that is not the right way to go
can i go in here and still locked okay
um i never looked in the bathroom
that's dark
okay i feel like i should take a look at
that
it smells awful
the pipes must be clogged
it doesn't really do anything when i
look at it i don't think
chains
chains do not use maybe i can break them
with something why would you want to use
it bro
what if we just didn't i don't feel like
that's necessary at all
oh
combination
right five left
maybe that's
right five left oh i should take that
all right
something right five left
the fall
left is fi i don't know what that means
blue
knees is real
blue knees
you talking you talking about you
talking about head
oh the collectibles cool
okay
okay got it cool cool cool cool cool
cool sweet sweet sweet sweet sweet cool
cuckoo
love everything that's going on right
now actually
it's just the bathroom all right
i feel like this is gonna jump scare me
for sure right look at it [ __ ] me okay
hello
hello everybody
hello there
okay we're fine it's fine
nothing
is wrong
at all hello cat
grandpa dedicated his whole life to
clock making
it's actually very cool
just what nine o'clock at nine o'clock
but uh 9 12 1.
maybe just the thing 9 12 1.
i could try it
why else would that be that right
okay let me
see what's through the crack here
hate that hate that a lot
just noise
hmm okay
very cool i can reach that
it's too high up
another collectible up
here closer
oh just back to the kitchen all right
i'm going to try 9 12
1 and maybe nine twelve two
or nine twelve and then what was that
that notebook said far left five
that would make it
five nine twelve a lot of clock stuff
going on in here huh
just give it we'll give it a shot we'll
give it a shot
this way
anything in here changed
i recognize it probably just wants me to
go to the basement but um
you can't
oh
why are we so puffed
try
nine
[Music]
twelve
one
uh far right five
so i call f5
nine
twelve
i didn't think so
oh
one two five eight let's try that i
don't know how i didn't see that last
time one
two
one throw away on that one
five
eight
no oh there's one two three four of you
okay we'll just give these a try
it's surely gonna be something that i'll
find way later in the game though
nope
two one two five
oh there's tons of them
that stuff someone's tried already he's
my guess
yeah i feel like the cockroach thing i
don't know if i'm reading too much into
way too many facets of this but i feel
like it's telling me hey you want ready
to do this yet so just go away like
that's what the game design intent was
it just wants me to go to the basement
randall
in the basement
a-okay
what could go wrong
rob why are you so tired
there isn't a red door in the basement
not that i can see
red door
basement but you said stay away from the
bugs dude
they're everywhere maybe just take a
picture of it
okay
oh well that's fun
i'm gonna take another picture
well i got the bugs off the door
nothing else i'm gonna if i take a
picture of it on the ground see if
no you gotta walk over
okay
oh cool
what oh great what is this this is a
demonic hallucination my friend i'm glad
you asked
what
you're being possessed i'm glad you lost
nothing
okay
those symbols
i've seen them before have you i don't
know what these [ __ ] symbols are dude
no idea where have i seen those before
huh okay
four of them all right we're gonna have
to search that's like a crime scene well
yeah i think this might be where you
killed your homies
nice
um
okay there's anything else right here
it doesn't appear to be
[Music]
this is making me so [ __ ] nervous
wait this one
i don't think so
all right cool
so i guess i gotta find the correct
symbols i didn't have anything like that
in my notebook did i
that's where the symbols are gonna be is
probably on
on those um
maybe i need to go back and look at the
pictures of the
corpsey bits oh gosh i actually think
i'm gonna leave it here
because it's we have we have objectives
this is definitely way more puzzly than
i expected it to be this is this is
gonna be
a very interesting ongoing puzzle to
solve i think which is super exciting
always love that um
i'm enjoying it so far i really do not
like the the voice performance
unfortunately um definitely no shade to
the actor i you know i know the studio
doesn't have a big budget or anything
and i feel like it's like potentially a
little obtuse but i can also overthink
puzzles so dramatically so it could
entirely be my fault um but i'm really
liking it so far let me know if you guys
want to see more i think i'll stream it
on twitch but if people are really
enjoying it then i'll uh upload more to
youtube as well but otherwise i plan to
stream it tonight so
thank you for watching everybody i'm
gonna try and go to bed
what could go wrong